Let's see if we can learn a
thing or two about partial
fraction expansion, or
sometimes it's called partial
fraction decomposition.
The whole idea is to take
rational functions-- and a
rational function is just a
function or expression where
it's one expression divided by
another-- and to essentially
expand them or decompose
them into simpler parts.
And the first thing you've got
to do, before you can even
start the actual partial
fraction expansion process, is
to make sure that the
numerator has a lower degree
than the denominator.
In the situation, the problem,
that I've drawn right here,
I've written right here,
that's not the case.
The numerator has the same
degree as the denominator.
So the first step we want to do
to simplify this and to get it
to the point where the
numerator has a lower degree
than the denominator is
to do a little bit of
algebraic division.
And I've done a video on this,
but it never hurts to get a
review here, so to do that, we
divide the denominator into the
numerator to figure out the
remainder, so we divide x
squared minus 3x minus 40 into
x squared minus 2x minus 37.
So how many times?
You look at the highest degree
term, so x squared goes into x
squared one time, one times
this whole thing is x squared
minus 3x minus 40, and now you
want to subtract this from
that to get the remainder.
And see, if I'm subtracting, so
I'm going to subtract, and then
minus minus is a plus, a plus,
and then you can add them.
These cancel out.
Minus 2x plus 3x, that's x.
Minus 37 plus 40,
that's plus 3.
So this expression up here can
be rewritten as-- let me scroll
down a little bit-- as 1 plus x
plus 3 over x squared
minus 3x minus 40.
This might seem like some type
of magic thing I just did, but
this is no different than what
you did in the fourth or fifth
grade, where you learned how
to convert improper regular
fractions into mixed numbers.
Let me just do a little
side example here.
If I had 13 over 2, and I want
to turn it into a mixed number,
what you do-- you can probably
do this in your head now-- but
what you did is, you divide the
denominator into the numerator,
just like we did over here.
2 goes into 13.
We see 2 goes into 13 six
times, 6 times 2 is 12, you
subtract that from that,
you get a remainder of 1.
2 doesn't go into 1, so
that's just the remainder.
So if you wanted to rewrite
this, it would be the number of
times the denominator goes into
the numerator, that's 6, plus
the remainder over
the denominator.
Plus 6-- plus 1 over 2.
And when you did it in
elementary school, you would
just write 6 1/2, but 6 1/2 is
the same thing as 6 plus 1/2.
That's exactly the same
thing we did here.
The denominator went to the
numerator one time, and then
there was a remainder of x plus
3 left over, so it's 1 plus x
plus 3 over this expression.
Now we see that that numerator
in this rational expression
does have a lower degree
than the denominator.
The highest degree here is 1,
the highest degree here is 2,
so we're ready to commence our
partial fraction decomposition.
And all that is, is taking this
expression up here and turning
it into two simpler expressions
where the denominators are the
factors of this lower term.
So given that, let's
factor this lower term.
So let's see.
What two numbers add up to
minus 3, and when you multiply
them, you get minus 40?
So let's see.
They have to be different
signs, because when you
multiply them you get a
negative, so it has to
be minus 8 and plus 5.
So we can rewrite this up here
as-- I'll switch colors--
1 plus x plus 3 over x
plus 5 times x minus 8.
5 times 8 is minus 40-- 5 times
negative 8 is minus 40, plus 5
minus 8 is minus 3,
so we're all set.
Now I'll just focus on
this part right now.
We can just remember
that that 1 is sitting
out there out front.
This is the expression we
want to decompose or expand.
And we're going to expand it
into two simpler expressions
where each of these are the
denominator-- and I will make
the claim, and if the numbers
work out then the claim is
true-- I'll make the claim that
I can expand this, or decompose
this, into two fractions where
the first fraction is just some
number a over the first factor,
over x plus 5, plus some
number b over the second
factor, over x minus 8.
That's my claim, and if I can
solve for a and b in a way that
it actually does add up to
this, then I'm done and I will
have fully decomposed
this fraction.
I guess is the way-- I
don't know if that's the
correct terminology.
So let's try to do that.
So if I were to add these
two terms, what do I get?
When you add anything, you find
the common denominator, and the
common denominator, the easiest
common denominator, is to
multiply the two denominators,
so let me write this here.
So a over x plus 5 plus b
over x minus 8 is equal to--
well, let's get the common
denominator-- it's equal to
x plus 5 times x minus 8.
And then the a term, we would--
a over x plus 5 is the same
thing as a times x minus
8 over this whole thing.
I mean, if I just wrote this
right here, you would just
cancel these two terms out and
you would get a over x plus 5.
And then you could add that to
the common denominator, x plus
5 times x minus 8, and it
would be b times x plus 5.
Important to realize,
that, look.
This term is the exact same
thing as this term if you just
cancel the x minus 8 out, and
this term is the exact same
thing as this term if you just
cancel the x plus 5 out.
But now that we have an actual
common denominator, we can add
them together, so we get-- let
me just write the left side
here over-- a over x
plus 5-- I'm sorry.
I want to write this over here.
I want to write x plus 3 over
plus 5 times x minus 8 is equal
to is equal to the sum of
these two things on top.
a times x minus 8 plus b times
x plus 5, all of that over
their common denominator, x
plus 5 times x minus eight.
So the denominators are the
same, so we know that this,
when you add this together,
you have to get this.
So if we want to solve
for a and b, let's just
set that equality.
We can ignore the denominators.
So we can say that x plus 3
is equal to a times x minus
8 plus b times x plus 5.
Now, there's two ways to
solve for a and b from
this point going forward.
One is the way that I was
actually taught in the seventh
or eighth grade, which tends to
take a little longer, then
there's a fast way to do it and
it never hurts to do
the fast way first.
If you want to solve for a,
let's pick an x that'll
make this term disappear.
So what x would make
this term disappear?
Well, if I say x is minus 5,
then this becomes 0, and
then the b disappears.
So if we say x is minus 5-- I'm
just picking an arbitrary x to
be able to solve for this--
then this would become minus 5
plus 3-- let me just write it
out, minus 5 plus 3-- is equal
to a times minus 5 minus 8--
let me just write it out,
minus 5 minus 8-- plus
b times minus 5 plus 5.
And I picked the minus 5 to
make this expression 0.
So then you get-- pick a
brighter color-- minus 5 plus
3 is minus 2, is equal to--
what is this?-- minus 13a
plus-- this is 0, right?
That's 0.
Minus 5 plus 5 is 0, 0 times b
is 0, and then you divide both
sides by minus 13, you get--
negatives cancel out-- you get
2 over 13 is equal to a, and
now we can do the same thing up
here and get rid of the a terms
by making x is equal to 8.
If x is equal to 8, you get x
plus 3 is equal to 11, is equal
to a times 0 plus b times--
what's 5-- 8 plus 5
is-- plus b times 13.
Their b looks a bit like a 13.
And then you get 11 is equal to
13b, divide both sides by 13,
you get b is equal
to 11 over 13.
So we were able to solve
for our a's and our b's.
And so we can go back to
our original equation
and we could say, wow.
This just has to be equal to
2 over 13, and this just has
to be equal to 11 over 13.
So our original, our very
original thing we wrote up
here, can be decomposed into 1,
that's this 1 over here, plus
this, which is 2 over 13-- I'll
just write it like this for
now-- 2 over 13, over x plus 5.
You could bring the 13 down
here if you want to write
it so you don't have a
fraction over a fraction.
Plus 11 over 13 times--
over x minus 8.
And once again, you could bring
the 13 down so you don't have
a fraction over a fraction.
But we have just successfully
decomposed this pretty-- I
don't want to say that we
necessarily simplified it,
because you could say, oh, we
only have one expression here,
now I have three-- but I've
reduced the degree of both the
numerators and the
denominators.
And you might say, well,
Sal, why would I ever
have to do this?
And you're right.
In algebra you probably won't.
But this is actually a really
useful technique later on when
you get to calculus, and
actually, differential
equations, because a lot of
times it's much easier-- and
I'll throw out a word here that
you don't understand-- to take
the integral or the
antiderivative of
something like this, then
something like this.
And later, when you do inverse
Laplace transforms and
differential equations, it's
much easier take an inverse
Laplace transform of
something like this than
something like that.
So anyway, hopefully I've given
you another tool kit in your--
or another tool in your tool
kit, and I'll probably do a
couple more videos because we
haven't exhausted all of the
examples that we could we
could show for partial
fraction decomposition.